hello everyone imagine you were playing
chess online and you were playing the
opponent after opponent after opponent
and then I don't know where an opponent
shows up and he's rated somewhere around
2700 to something and you managed to win
that game and you feel free pretty good
about yourself and then two months after
that game you realize that that opponent
was actually Magnus Carlsen world
champion Magnus Carlsen at that such is
the case what happened here it's a game
between table our own israeli
grandmaster and magnus carlsen
the game was played in 2015 on ICC and
Magnus Carlsen was using the handle stop
tryharding now in the description below
I will put a link to the original
footage of this game from top arune's
livestream and feel free to check that
out as well and for those of you who
follow what's going on in the chess
world on the Internet
I'm sure you know there was some
controversy too-tall Baron and his
cheating and on the title tuesday event
on chess calm but i will revisit that
after i show you the game so in this
game table ron has the white pieces and
he plays d4 we have Knight to f6 by
cousin c4 e6 Knight to c3 and a Bishop
to b4 the names on Indian defense and
here like in the previous video like via
KHOU at Alba Ron goes for f3 the Kamal
variation we have D 5 a 3 now kicking
the bishop but Bishop captures on c3 be
captures on c3 and c5 by Carlsen we have
a C capture son d5e captures on d5 and
III Carlsen castles and we have Bishop
to d3 b6 now and nice to e2 preparing
Knights to g3 and at some point white
would enjoy pushing efore and E 5
definitely if possible so bush up to a 6
now white castles we have rook to e8
attacking the e3 pawn and night the g3
Bishop captures Queen captures and we
have Knight to c6 Bishop to b2 now
reinforcing the d4 pawn and h5 and in
this moment as you you will see in the
original footage if you check it out
there is a thing to consider here that
respond to h4 and like I said white
would definitely want
pushy foreign d-5 if possible so if or
at this point would be an excellent move
if if if black would allow it you have
to calculate what happens when black
pushes h4 so boron goes for it he pushes
efore we have h4 immediately by Carlson
and now Knight to f5 d captures on e 4f
captures on e4 and Knight captures on e4
and here there are a lot of things to
consider across and just one upon and if
you'd wanna play the absolute most
precise move that would be rook a to e1
where white gets most for his pawn but
da goes for the for the more complicated
variation he plays Queen to f3 and here
of course you do have to realize night 2
D to move will night - D - sorry will
for the Queen and the rook but this
would actually be a pretty bad move if
Knight to d2 immediately then simply
night to h6 and you can't capture the
pawn you have to play a kink to h7
followed by Queen to h5 this will be
completely winning for white if you
capture the night then Queen captures f7
check King h8 rook to f6 and there is no
defense against rook captures on h6
cousin we have to give up the Queen so
after this Queen to f3 move Carson has
the option of playing Queen to f6 and
this would actually be perfectly fine
for black pretty much stops everything
white had planned but I also knew that
tal's plan was was definitely night to
h6 check he played C capture Sundy for
as he calculated that night to h6 check
doesn't work but Baron goes for it he
plays Knight to h6 check caution
immediately captures we have Queen
Catherine on f7 King to h8 and now C
captures and the for preparing d5
opening up a discover check from the
bishop to the King Crossin plays Queen
to g5 and here was the idea before d5
move doesn't work if you play d5
immediately Knight to e5 the rook and
Queen protect the knight on e5 very
nicely and after rook to f5 cousin has
Knight to d6 with a fork on the Queen
and the rook and the white doesn't have
any compensation for the sacrifice piece
but instead after this defy moved out
plays rook 81 and again it's a pretty
it's a very complicated position and in
this position calls and played Queen to
g7 and this is the move that actually
gives a towel bar on the upper hand
cross and missed in this position this
very devious h3 move what you have to
calculate is d5 of course Knight to e5
defending from Czech Queen to f3 now
guarding g2 the knight can capture
because it's bent but now Knight to the
d2 actually wins for black you fork the
Queen and the rook and this is a hard
move to find Queen captures on h3 and
now King to g8 is actually in the
winning move for black now black doesn't
really have anything if rook captures
rook captures Bishop captures and Queen
captures there is pretty much no
compensation for the piece whatsoever
but as this is a blitz game Carlson was
better on time but he didn't find this
plate Queen to g7 and now comes Queen
captures King captors and now d5 winning
back the piece if you block with Knight
to e5 then rook captures on D and E 4 is
coming so King to g6 now pawn captures
and here we have rook a to C 8r up to f4
now with a double attack on b4 night
night the c5 and here we have rook to f6
check and here Carlson has two options
King h5 and King to g5 King to h5 allows
him to play on it you know Baron was a
very long time he would have to work
hard to win this game but Carson played
King to g5 and here it's it's just over
rook to f1 doubling up rooks and
preparing group 2 c1 check and there was
really no good way to stop this Carlsen
played h3 but this simply runs into mate
in 5
we had Bishop the c1 checked by tal
kingi for rook to g6 check King to h5
characters on h6 check King g4 and now a
checkmate would upon G captures on h3
and this is checkmate so he was very
satisfied about winning this game he won
against 27
plus player you know everyone would be
very satisfied and it was only two
months after this that he realized that
stop trihard stop tryharding is actually
magnus carlsen sandal on ICC so he went
back to check the logs and he saw that
he indeed did play a game against Magnus
Carlsen so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and now I said I
will remove is it that controversy I
spoke of in the beginning of the video
now it was it was it was regarding the
title to use the event and chess comm
table Arun was accused of cheating there
of using an engine now how this is a
this is a pretty pretty big thing
because try googling tall bar on Google
will immediately offer to finish your
sentence with al-biruni cheating so this
is a like I said quite quick but I've
spoken to top bar on in the past year
for a couple of a couple of times as
I've spoken to him over Skype we spoke
about many things and this particular
matter about him cheating what actually
happened was he was playing a tournament
at idle Tuesday event and chess calm and
he won the tournament he was accused of
cheating in the last round of the
tournament but he already won the
tournament before that last round even
began he was eight out of eight and in
the ninth round he faced an opponent who
he knew who he knew was an engine user
so here he had a choice you either play
against an engine user and you know I
voluntarily lose rating and points or
you can I mean there's really nothing
you can do if you know you're playing
against an engine user only thing you
can do is lose the game but instead a
huge an engine of his own and in the end
that game ended in a draw
which can prove that both of them were
using an engine for this he got his
accountant just outcome banned and
pretty much no one ever really wanted to
do any collaboration with him or
anything and what's the idea here I mean
what would you do in that situation
people said that if he used the engine
in the last round and he probably used
the engine in all the other rounds and
that he probably uses the engine all the
time and after that thing happened then
people started saying that he actually
probably used the engine in this game
against Magnus Carlsen as well and while
I can't really I mean I don't know what
happened I can only tell you from my
personal experience I've spoken to him
many times over Skype and I I don't
think he's that kind of a person of
course he could be a sociopath and I
could totally judge his character
incorrectly but then again and anyone on
the internet who plays chess could be an
engine user I could be an engine user
and every one of you could be also an
engine user but saying that publicly
that someone is an engine user
especially a Toblerone who is a
grandmaster who devoted his entire life
to chess with a rating of almost 2600 I
believe is without any ironclad evidence
is basically just a witch-hunt and you
know people do enjoy a good winch
witch-hunt want people a one-person
yells which and you know they're already
warming up the state so I don't know I I
mean I checked this situation out I've
googled some ideas and read it and such
and I've seen some evidence posted there
but none of that is really evidence they
just said that you know he couldn't have
played that great and okay does seem a
bit suspicious that you know he defeated
a lot of tires from strong top
grandmasters in that tournament but
saying that he cheated just because he
couldn't possibly play that strong is
just ridiculous I remember two years ago
I defeated a feed a master in like 20
moves simply because he attacked me and
I had to play the the only move to win
that game or I would lose that game so
basically if you put that game on you
know on analysis the computer will say I
played every move like an engine but I
only you know I only found it the only
move that could actually prolong the
game and in the end I won a game in 20
moves against defeated master and there
are a lot of a lot of you know examples
like this but saying that he cheated in
any other instance because he simply
played great
I don't know that's that's like formal
logic that's what they use to prove a
woman is a witch to burn her on a stake
so once again I can't really prove that
this is true or that this isn't true but
I really hated that without any evidence
to the contrary people are publicly
saying that he's a cheater and but yes
that's what I wanted to say I can tell
you that in that game against Magnus
Carlsen I will put a link in the
description below feel free to click on
it there you can see the game as it's
played live on his livestream and you
can hear his thoughts about every move
what he's thinking about and what I
wanted to tell you that is that for him
to even though he doesn't know he's
playing against Magnus Carlsen but even
if that were not the case even if he
knew that that was Magnus Carlsen
since I told you I know tell Barone and
I've spoken to him many times I can tell
you that he is too big of a computer
noob to pull off something like that
during livestream I mean I do videos I
do live streams and there is no way for
you to be able to set up an engine to be
able to use it on a website midstream so
that it would work properly you know
especially in a three minute game that's
that is not possible especially not for
Toblerone who is I'm telling you he's a
computer noob he would he would he has
no idea how to set that up so yeah I
didn't want to really get into into a
lot of things here I just you know
wanted to share my opinion on this on
this channel here I run and I will put
another link in the description below
where it can watch at Oberon's video
where he explains what happens and it's
a pretty long video so I recommend you
watch it on a double speed because he
was it was very emotional and
grief-stricken about the entire thing
here so you know it it's a pretty long
video so yeah basically this is the game
I wanted to show you and I hope you
check out both of the links in the
description below and figure out things
for ourselves rather than just
googling Toblerone cheats that's you
know that's just what everyone else is
doing so yeah I would like to think Phil
is not a dad for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon